that's necessarily dominated by that I
shot it automatically this is it it's
dominated by about there we do inclusion
of a bit Amy you try to say don't
there's also faces wall because it
doesn't seem too much here's my view
able Tamia is the even Tamia is the most
intellectual humble light that ever
lived
obviously in terms of intellectual
contribution to Islam he is number one
you can already say second to element
himself that was the only thing you
could say second to but even then his
contribution is higher than a man's in
certain areas way to it she did right so
as a humble like myself I'm a handle I'm
homily I follow the method I'm a madman
myself right
or I tried to at least some long great I
well as a handle up myself
I was refreshed to see this happy to see
this did the chef muhammad saw three
other for a weekend there you know I'll
try said from from the hand of your
mother and he has this challenge but I
mean is that he is he is that figure he
is that figure radius so it's not you
know why he should be an inspiration to
all Santa Fe's and in the innocence
sense that look what he did I mean you
can't say well that was just exclusive
to him you can't say he company the
argument he did these things how did he
push you knowledge the he pursue
knowledge by locking himself in the
reason reading a soul Sunnah and God
wahat his book he didn't sorry I didn't
do that
this is this close-minded intially right
is gonna lead though much destruction
because what it will do is well I'm not
saying everyone should go and study
philosophy by the way just to be clear
right but what I'm saying at the same
time is people should be at least
introduced to basic ideas that were
talking about liberalism and feminism
and things like that so they can protect
themselves like an antidote towards it
and in Tama if he hadn't contributed we
would be in problems and if we don't
contribute today and for all I met don't
contribute then we're gonna be in
formulas once again so I think now we
have challenges that entertainment
didn't have a nice time yeah liberalism
wasn't there at this time REM taymiyah
and neither was feminism new
intellectual challenges
we have to deal with them yeah I wasn't
in sushi yeah yeah yeah and you have to
do with them by using the language
wasn't about well we're dealing with a
ridiculous scale yes oh oh I'm not a fun
book it's on Amazon I think it's a
pistol allow India in the atheist it's
actually over take over taking the air
would you call it God you know when that
happened I thought to myself this is a
bit crazy because this is you know I
don't see many other Muslims right you
know in the intersection so surprised
so each other has got many many atheists
right in our section absolutely man he's
about Mohammed about thinking why is it
that they get to do this with us and we
don't get to talk about things with them
and it's not even a you know you'll find
that probably atheists will use my
arguments do not say over yeah I mean
the job said that you know something
about infinity right because it's
actually I'm not I'm looking at the
thing with the most critical eye
possible I'm looking at all of the in
the follow and then I the end of it I
come to the conclusion that this is this
is a commune ever be able to deal with
basically this is the argument that
you're never gonna be able as an atheist
but you're always happen with this yeah